What I'd like to talk about now is a little bit more detail
on some of the different ways that we have to generate random inputs
to our software under test.
So let's start off with our diagram showing the random test case generator.
If you recall from the diagram a little bit earlier in this unit,
this test case generator has 2 inputs.
It takes pseudo-random numbers from a pseudo-random number generator,
and it's also predicated on some amount of knowledge of the input domain,
and that's supplied by a human.
We already looked at one example--testing the outer--
where essentially no domain knowledge was needed.
That is to say, the random test case generator pretty much took its pseudo-random numbers
and used them directly as test cases.
We looked at a different example--that is to say, the credit card number generator--
where pseudo-random numbers, part of the input,
and they weren't directly parroted to the output
but rather they parameterized an algorithm which created valid credit card numbers.
And of course it's possible to carry that kind of logic farther,
as in the example of where we're testing a file system
and we need to generate valid sequences of API calls
or testing a web browser where we need to actually generate well-formed HTML
in order to test certain parts of the browser.
But it turns out all of these ways of generating input are variations on a single theme
which we call generative random testing.
Generative random testing simply means that inputs are created from scratch.
There's an entirely different approach called mutation-based random testing.
Inputs are created by randomly modifying existing non-randomly created inputs
to the software under test.
And so what that does is changes our diagram a little bit
so that we have a separate source of input which is the existing test case.
One thing we might ask ourselves is, which approach is better?
As far as I know, there is no cut-and-dried answer to that.
Sometimes generative works really well;
sometimes mutation-based testing works really well,
and it really just depends on the situation and how much time you have to spend.
In general, my view is that generative testing might be a little bit better
at ferreting out really weird errors, but it's a lot more work to create entire random tests--
at least if there are sophisticated constraints on their form--from scratch.
Mutation testing, on the other hand, has a different strength, so let's take a look at that.